[موسيقى]
القبله هي وجهه المصلي وبيت المقدس هي
قبله المسلمين قبل هجره النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وفي 17 رجب من السنه الثانيه
للهجره تحولت القبله من بيت المقدس الى
مكه المكرمه والقبله تحدث عن طريق النجوم
في الليل وعن طريق الشمس في النهار فالشمس
اساسا في تحديد مواقيت الصلاه وتحديد
القبله اراني اذا صليت يممت نحوها بوجه
وان كان المصلى ورائيه وما به اشراك ولكن
حبها وعظم الجوى اعيا الطبيب
المداويه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذا الاسبوع الشمس تكون هي القبله
وقت اذان الظهر على الحرم خاصه في يوم 27
28 29 مايو فالشمس في هذا الوقت الساعه
12:27 دقيقه تكون فوق الكعبه على مستوى
العالم بمعنى ان الذي يشاهد الشمس سواء
كان عندهم صبح او ظهر او عصر فهو مستقبل
للقبله والشمس تكون فوق الكعبه او تمر على
الكعبه مرتين بسنه مرت وهي طالعه فوق
لمدار سرطان في 27 مايو ومره ثانيه وهي
نازله تحت لمدار الجدي في 16 يوليو قد نرى
تقلب وجهك في السماء فلا نولينك قبله
ترضاها هو اللي وجهك شطر المسجد الحرامي
وحيث ما كنتم فولو وجوهكم شاطره
[موسيقى]